Scott Pruett was elected Attorney
General of Oklahoma in 2010 he received
his Bachelor of Arts in political
science and communications from
Georgetown College and a JD from the
University of Tulsa College of Law he
served for eight years in the Oklahoma
State Senate where he was an advocate
for fiscal responsibility religious
freedom and the right to life as
Attorney General he established
Oklahoma's federalism unit to combat
unwarranted regulation and overreach by
the federal government
he brought suit against the Affordable
Care Act and remains a zealous advocate
for religious freedom and the sanctity
of all human life he is a past president
of the Republican attorneys general
Association and he was even a successful
general managing partner of the Oklahoma
Redhawks minor league baseball team
please join me in welcoming Attorney
General Scott Pruitt
well that's very nice of Andrew just say
those nice things but also to reference
the baseball portion it's it's an
unusual thing to have someone in
politics that's also on the baseball
team so I hear it happened just a few
years ago right here and here in town
but that we did own the Oklahoma City
Redhawks there in Oklahoma City for a
number of years and very much enjoyed my
time
good to see Hans welcome I'm very much
blessed for for many reasons today but
I'm glad I'm airily because I'm joined
by my daughter there's actually over at
Heritage staying at the Heritage campus
and very much appreciate my kin is in
the back so I'm very thankful to be able
to see her she took me to a great dinner
last night in honor of Father's Day and
so we've had a good time in town but I'm
excited to visit with you about this
issue of the next Supreme Court justice
and the role of the court presently as
we look to the future and and I think it
is a very key and strategic time and I
want to begin by just asking and in
commenting you know there's certain
times in history that as we are living
them we know that we're living in a very
important time we know that we're making
history for the future we know that the
founders recognized that we know that
the founders recognized that in
correspondence and letters to one
another about the posterity of that
which they were creating we see that
from World War Two as well just
historical moments that we that we know
that the actions being taken by
individuals at that time are not just
about that generation or about that
particular issue but it's about what's
going to hurt her in the future for many
decades ahead and there are other times
in history that that they're very
significant but we don't recognize them
as much pope john paul ii as an example
june 2nd of 1979 was the first pope to
ever enter into a communist country he
went back to his homeland in poland and
gave a series of sermons over a week or
so period talking about the importance
of his countrymen responding to the
fabrications that were being propagated
by the communist government at that time
fact he said two things to them you're
not who they say you are let me remind
you who you are now at the time that
wasn't in the history books at the time
there was not much written about the
Pope entering into
and the significance of that of that
series of sermons but a decade later
historians look back and said that was
the beginning of the Solidarity movement
and and thus led to the fall of
communism so as we gather here today as
we gather in Washington DC and always
get nostalgic when I come to Washington
DC and I look at all the monuments and I
go to the Capitol Hill and I see
statuary hall and and I see the great
commitment the great love of Liberty
that our founders possess but as we
gather here today I would ask you the
question rhetorically is this a time
that's an historical moment as it
relates to our constitutional fabric is
it is that a significant time in history
as we look forward into the decades
ahead that the decisions are being made
today are they going to impact the
Liberty to the degree that we've seen
historically and I would say to you that
I think that we are living in such a
time in fact I would say to you that the
judicial branch in many instances is the
last surviving branch of our
constitutional framework when you look
at the executive branch today it's
acting like the legislative branch you
have the executive branch that's used a
regulatory power to engage in
legislative types of action and they're
thereby creating this balance in balance
of power between the legislative branch
and the executive branch and the
legislative branch is not doing much
better either in fact in many instances
it's not showing up to work and I don't
mean that literally but in the passage
of laws it is truly abdicated the
responsibility you know there's
something in the Constitution called the
non delegation doctrine but yet we see
those in Congress routinely doing what
delegating authority to the executive
branch to do its job there are many
examples of that
and so I really think as we look at the
judicial branch it is the last surviving
branch because you can go before a US
Supreme Court today or an Oklahoma
Supreme Court or a court in this country
engage in advocacy and the court will
make a decision so it is functional but
I'll say - we're at a tipping point even
in that branch of government as well and
that's what I want to talk to you about
today is that though the judicial branch
is still functioning the question must
be asked will it function in the way
that the founders
tended into the future and so that's the
reason I think this discussion about
Justice Scalia the replacement of
Justice Scalia is such an important
question to ask and answer and to
address today now I get a chance to know
Justice Scalia personally he was someone
that I have a good friend Leonard Leo
who is the executive vice president at
the Federalist Society and Leonard
blessed me on numerous occasions to to
spend some quality time personal time
with the previous justice in fact I
remember one year about three years ago
I was up here for a Federalist Society
event their annual meeting that occurs
in November Leonard said Scott stay over
I'd like free to go to dinner on Friday
night and anytime that Leonard asked you
to go to dinner you stay because he
feeds you well but but as I went to
dinner on that Friday night there was
someone of a surprise we went to a
basement here in Washington DC there was
about 10 of us in attendance 2 of those
folks in attendance were Justice Scalia
and Justice Thomas and we spent three
hours talking about the Constitution and
things that that we were involved in as
Attorney General
it was a fabulous time and Justice
Scalia was a person of brilliance great
intellectual prowess as you know but he
was also very witty very charming and
very personal we lost a patriot when
Justice Scalia passed but I want to say
to you as we look forward and I'm going
to share with you about five principles
five things that I think Justice Scalia
represented in his jurisprudence that
literally transformed how we think about
the law today but before I get there I
want you to know this is not just about
a vote I think often times we look at
the Supreme Court and we hear the debate
going on in Congress and and the US
Senate taking the position it's taken
the president taking the position he's
taking presently this isn't just about a
vote on the US Supreme Court that is
important we've seen that as recently as
last week this is about an attitude a
spirit a belief in what the judicial
branch should be focused upon in the
future and Justice Scalia I think was
five things that I think I can share
with you today that really demonstrate
the importance of individual on that
Court
and how they can make a difference in
the trajectory of that branch of
government in its impact on our
liberties and freedoms and so I'm going
to mention to you five things today that
I think that will draw attention to that
the first thing is that Justice Scalia
was a textualist and and you sometimes
hear that term and and you think it's
the same thing as original intent and
it's not justice scalia was a text list
in the sense that he believed that the
text of the law the text of the
constitution should control the outcome
and and that sounds were the simple
today that sounds were the straight-4
but before Justice Scalia was appointed
to the US Supreme Court and he began
this endeavor as focusing upon
textualism most courts if you look back
before 1987 that was a foreign concept
that a judge felt like that they were
constrained that they were restricted in
issuing and ruling based upon the actual
words of a law and the actual words of
the constitutional provision they
believed that they were able to add what
their own beliefs their own view of that
language and therefore we saw a
progressive mentality that took root in
the jurisprudence in this country but
Justice Scalia changed the trajectory in
a substantial way in fact Justice Kagan
she was quoted as saying that we're all
textualist now that that's that's the
impact that Justice Scalia had on this
debate and though it does sound simple
and though it does sound straightforward
it has had a profound impact I would say
to the point of general Meese when he
served as the Attorney General for
President Reagan began a discussion
about federalism and the concept of
federalism was something that had kind
of been pushed aside general Meese
revived that and I believe that Justice
Scalia also didn't revive textual ISM
but he gave it a meaning in life in a
way that has made a difference in to the
course since the late 1980s and what is
textual ism well text ilysm effectively
is we look at the law as written and we
apply the law as written we look at the
words used and give meaning to those
words and and if there are any gaps we
don't simply just fill in the gaps and
if they lead the bad policy Justice
Scalia was notorious at saying it's not
our jobs as judge as judges to make a
bad law good law you know to do the job
of Congress and so that textualism means
that sometimes there are outcomes that
you may find offensive from a policy
perspective I've had many examples as
Attorney General is I have taken actions
to enforce the statutes as drafted by
our legislative body there are many
times as I've looked at that I don't
agree with the policy of the law I don't
agree with what the legislative branch
has done but that is not my job as an
attorney general to pick and choose
which laws I choose to defend my job is
to carry out my responsibilities of the
Constitution to to enforce and execute
the laws that have been passed by the
legislative branch and Justice Scalia
would say the same thing as a judge give
meaning to the words give meaning to the
text and even if it leads to quote
unquote a bad outcome it's not the job
of the judge to fix that outcome and to
address the bad policy we've seen this
live and in color recently in fact
Oklahoma was the lead state in the state
health care exchange debate that that
followed as you know the original ACA
the NFIB versus Sebelius was the
constitutional type of case that
challenged facially the the authority of
Congress to even pass the Affordable
Care Act they have the authority to pass
it under the Commerce Clause which by
the way just a side note the Supreme
Court said no we forget that the Supreme
Court said that Congress did not possess
the constitutional authority under the
Commerce Clause to pass the ACA the
whole issue there was Chief Justice
Roberts found that they could under
taxing power power and use that to
justify the law's existence on its face
but we followed up with that a case
dealing with the state health care
exchanges where the Congress set up this
framework between federal and state
exchanges and if states didn't set up a
state exchange guess what Congress said
subsidies could not be issued in those
states tax credits could not be issued
to offset the rising cost of health care
in so
that was the literal language that was
the literal impact of that law and when
we challenged it we lost that case
before the US Supreme Court largely in
my opinion because of the policy outcome
if people would not have access to
subsidies so Justice Scalia spoke very
assertively in the dissent about that
very issue so the point I'm trying to
make with textualism is that it's not a
matter of do we agree with the policy
did we agree with the outcome the job of
the the jurist is to look at the
language and give meaning in life to the
actual words used and and that's it the
second thing that leads to that leads
that the first one reads to the sec
second principle that I think Justice
Scalia utilized and that he was an
originalist not only was it a text list
he was an originalist but not in the way
that you might think we hear a lot about
original intent and in our discussion
with respect to the digital branch in
jurisprudence but but Justice Scalia was
an originalist in the sense of saying
the words that were used must be
interpreted must be understood as they
were understood at the time that the law
was passed it'd be like you entered into
a contract and and to buy a home or to
buy a business or to engage in some sort
of transaction you enter into the
contract and then there's a dispute
about some aspect of that contract and
then there's a litigation that occurs
when you go before the court Justice
Scalia would say that the provisions the
terms the language used in that contract
should be understood at the time the
contract was drafted even if it was 10
or 15 or 20 years ago and not to be
reimagined not to be reinterpreted based
upon the language and they understand
those words today and so that's that's
the way he was an originalist and that
combination of textual ISM and r''l ISM
is very powerful with respect to his
focus on the role of the court and
recognizing the third principle that I
think is terribly important and that's
respect for rule of law and and rule of
law is something that I know that often
times when we hear it maybe not in this
room but I think in society that we
think it's a quaint concept in the 18th
century we think it's an academic or a
legal principle and it's not that
important
rule of law is essential to how we do
business as a country rule of law means
that laws are stable they are static and
as a citizen you can look at that law
what's constitutional or statutory and
you can take confidence that that is a
static expectation of you and you can
plan accordingly you know there are
certain portions of the tax code that I
don't like particularly the percentages
of what's expected of me but but but I
can look at that statute I can look at
that law and I can say that's what's
expected of me from an obligation as far
as taxes and I can plan accordingly
I can set money aside I can you know
take money out of my paper whatever it
is that I need to do to comply with that
particular expectation that rule of law
allows me to plan and allows me to
govern my life accordingly now the
opposite of that is is the inconsistency
of not going to look at a lost attic and
it's interesting in today's legal
context and I deal with this everyday is
attorney general I can Minnie I can
mention many cases to you where this is
the case where a regulatory agency after
the fact after a law is passed well take
a statute that is plain and ambiguous
and say we're going to re-imagine we're
going to we're going to amend now they
don't call it that but that's their
action they they execute a rule to
change the language of a statute it's
happened in numerable it's happened in
the ACA context it's happened under the
Clean Air Act it's happened under the
Clean Water Act the waters the United
States case that we were just involved
in as a collection of states I led that
effort it was a reimagining of what
constitutes the water of the United
States for one fundamental reason the
EPA wanted Authority jurisdiction power
over decision making on how you use your
land and so that is a that's an example
of an individual or a business being
governed by a regulatory body that
changes a statute after its passed
thereby injuring rule of law and what
does that create instability and
uncertainty you know we have many issues
that's a sidebar comment fiscal policy
tax policy are all very important
to our ability to grow an economy in the
future but I would submit to you the
greatest impediment to economic growth
in the country today is regulatory
uncertainty in regulatory power and it
can be it can truly be described as an
abuse fundamentally of rule of law and
so Justice Scalia Justice Scalia by
applying textualism by applying
originalism would say to you that that
leads to a respect for rule of law it
leads to a respect of those that
represents us in Congress if you ever
thought and I mentioned this to my folks
in Oklahoma again a sidebar comment why
is federalism so important why are these
issues of rule of law is so important
one it creates this confidence you know
and it allows people to plan and deploy
capital and hire personnel in the rest
but Oklahoma you all probably don't know
this off the top your head we have all
of seven people here in Washington DC
representatives to US senators and five
congressmen now I would ask you a
question rhetorically if we yield a
decision to Washington DC that should be
made by the state of Oklahoma either
under the Constitution or the statute
that Congress has passed we suffer
because seven individuals representing
us in Washington DC are never going to
be able to compete with Illinois Ohio
Texas Florida Oh California New York all
these large that have a factor of seven
that represent those states and so the
founders understood that and they
understood the importance of a little
law and and and when and when Congress
gives primacy to the states as they did
in the Clean Air Act or the or the
constitutional framework through
separation of power
excuse me through separation through
federalism gives the the right to the
states and it's disrespected then an
injures rule of law and in Justice
Scalia I think recognize that insurers
prudence in a very meaningful way so
that's the third thing that I would
share with you is that textualism and
originalism leads to respect for rule of
law it's not a living document it's not
a breathing document the Constitution
it's not a document that allows jurist
on the US Supreme Court to discover new
rights
to do what to apply the text and
recognize the rights given through the
actual language now many of the cases
that we see of late that have caused
such a disruption such a an outcry
across the country are our rights that
have truly been quote-unquote discovered
through what the Fourteenth Amendment
and substantive process and so that's
the reason Justice Scalia was so you
know opposed to this judicial philosophy
of discovering your rights and it's not
a living breathing document and the
effect on rule of law and the fourth
thing that I would share with you as far
as principles that Justice Scalia
represented and this is a meaningful one
all these are but this one to me
particularly enumerated rights were
unequivocal to Justice Scalia there were
no exceptions
and again it follows his his philosophy
of textual ism and originally but
originalism but let me tell you what
that means that means that he joined the
liberal side of the court in rendering
decisions the fly burning cases Justice
Scalia joined the progressive on the
court to say look the free speech is
enumerated right and enumerated power
and and he recognized the the the right
of individuals to burn flags very
unpopular and very unpopular with
conservatives particularly the Fourth
Amendment there was a case Marilyn
versus King where the state of Maryland
was connecting DNA samples upon
individuals who were arrested but never
charged
and Justice Scalia spoke assertively
again with the liberal wing of the court
to say that was inconsistent with the
Fourth Amendment obviously Justice
Scalia was the author of what the
hell're decision the Second Amendment
and that shows you how important his
replacement is going to be that was a
five-to-four decision that v that v vote
is obviously not an according to more
but he he wrote
wrote the opinion in the Second
Amendment the confrontation clause
Justice Scalia again this is all under
enumerated rights were non-negotiable to
Justice Scalia the confrontation clause
the Constitution that says that you have
a right to confront your accuser a state
passed a law at the Crawford case that
said that because the accuser was a
minor that the the accused could not
confront that person
Justice Scalia joined with the four
liberals of the court to say that was
inconsistent with the Constitution so
the point I'm trying to make is that all
flows from what fiction was an original
ism and he gave meaning life power if
you will to the enumerator rights of the
Constitution and then I think this the
the the the other area that the fifth
comment I would make about principles
that governed Justice Scalia's
philosophy judicial philosophy and its
importance as we go forward is he was a
constitutionalist and what I mean by
that is the he was a structural
federalism person we hear a lot about
federalism but but structural federalism
is something that we need to understand
what the founders separated powers
horizontally we all get that that's
fifth right civics between the branches
but they did something else that is as
important they separated power
vertically they enumerated power for the
federal government and reserve power to
the states and to the people and in that
vertical checks and balances that
vertical checks and power along with the
horizontal checks and balances that
structural federalism that's something
that that as we look at it the founders
believed that that was essential to
preserving our Liberty for the long term
and that is something that I believe
that Justice Scalia represented very
much in his opinions the very last thing
that that Justice Scalia did I don't
know if you know this or not was to
issue a stay in the clean power plan
case I was actually a part of West
Virginia and Oklahoma over part of the
decision to seek the US Supreme Court's
intervention to to stay the EPA's
enforcement of the clean power plan that
was adopted the final laws by the EPA
and we estimated there was about a 15%
chance of winning the last week of what
the last week of his life
Justice Scalia join with four other
members of the court and issued as they
should have say it was unprecedented and
they did it largely in my view because
of a case that happened the year before
Michigan versus EPA which we were also
part of that it dealt with mercury and
mercury rule and the EPA was required to
go through a cost-benefit analysis in
that that rule did so but because
benefit analysis didn't really play in
their favor there were billions dollars
of cost and this is not an exaggeration
billions of dollars of cost and millions
of dollars of benefit and so the EPA
just brushed it aside and said we're
going to adopt the rule anyway state
sued took us three years to get before
your supreme courting into victory in
2015
guess what happened in the interim the
APA forced that rule upon utility
companies and citizens throughout the
country and so practically they achieve
their their outcome yet they lost the
case
the EPA bragged about that post the
decision and they really did in press
releases in fact they actually said yeah
we lost but we accomplished our goal
anyway I think that particular case is
what drove the court to intervene in the
clean power plan case and Justice Scalia
led that intervention so that that
federalism notion structural federalism
notion that I'm making reference to was
demonstrated as recently as the clean
power plan decision I think as we go
forward we've got to ask the question
next not just what principals did did
Justice Scalia represent and his
jurisprudence and how he set a
trajectory that was important for the
judicial branch but what's at issue as
we go forward
constitutionally what cases what issues
do we think are going to be impacted by
who replaces Justice Scalia and whether
he or she possesses these
characteristics these principles that I
referenced and I think the first area I
would mention to you is religious
liberty
Hobby Lobby is a case that that you may
have heard about the Hobby Lobby
business is located and the corporate
headquarters are located in Oklahoma
City David Greene is a good friend of
mine but if you follow that case you
know that the Hobby Lobby was a Supreme
Court decision that stands for the
proposition that corporations actually
possess rights under the First Amendment
free speech and free exercise rights
privately held corporations that was the
distinction that the court offered that
publicly traded and I can unpack that
for you in question time if you want but
but we've seen several cases come before
the court Little Sisters of the Poor
this term came before the court no
resolution actually sent back to the
district court because of the four to
four split and that case is still being
litigated and with no outcome we had a
quick we had a case didn't certiorari
was denied recently a pharmacist a
pharmacist was was objecting to the
requirement that he issue or sell
abortion inducing drugs and the
pharmacist said that violates my first
minute beliefs and the state of
Washington said to get a license to be a
pharmacist you must do this or you won't
you won't be a pharmacist in the state
of Washington he sued lost the Ninth
Circuit ruled against this individual
sought certiorari before the court and
unfortunately cert was denied recently
so when we look at the religious liberty
context well it's in the Hobby Lobby
context the little sisters the poor our
case is like the pharmacists case that
is mentioned we can see that religious
liberty is going to be a very important
issue going forward and I would submit
to you this there is a real vigorous
debate that's ongoing about what does
the First Amendment actually protect
protect with respect to free exercise
and the debate is this the debate is
that some believe that we have a product
phase faith that we have a right to
worship and that's it
we don't have a right to engage to
exercise that the free exercise language
in the Constitution this simply gives
you the ability to get together on
Sunday or Saturday or whatever day of
worship you have and and and you can you
have the privatized faith but to engage
in the public square that's not
something the First Amendment protect I
was in Romania in 1997 traveling there
and spent some time with a church leader
there in Timisoara which is whether
Revolution occurred and I was going to
the church with this individual and up
on the wall there were pictures of
pastors in the 1950s and 1960s and I was
confused I asked the individual I said
did you meet in the 1950s did you meet
in the 1960s and the individual said yes
we met her of a week but as we met there
was always someone in attendance from
the government who monitored everything
that we said and if we went outside the
four walls of the church and shared what
we learned within the four walls
deserves we were arrested and prosecuted
that's what I mean about the protection
of right to worship versus the right of
engagement religious persuasion if you
will in the public square that is going
to be an issue going forward and we
already see it taking place those those
cases are are before us and they're
happening and this person remember this
person is that replaces Justice Scalia
the question must be asked are they
going to look at the the First Amendment
as an enumerated power an imminent right
that is unquestioned as I shared that he
did in other instances is he are they
going to look at it from a text List
perspective in an originalist
perspective as I've already shared in
determining whether you and I have free
exercise to engage in religious
persuasion and public square we don't
have a right not to be offended by the
way in the Constitution I think some are
trying to interpret that way but that is
going to be a very important matter
going forward with the court second area
also in the First Amendment's free
speech we know that with citizens united
there's a continual drumbeat here in
Washington DC with respect to citizens
united and corporate participate
in the electoral process let me dispel
them let me dispel an untruth it happens
at times in the political space citizens
united does not stand for the
proposition that there's unlimited
giving to a campaign that's not what
citizens united says citizens united
doesn't say that a corporation can give
unlimited amounts of money to a
candidate it says that they that a
corporation which legally is seen as a
person it always has been under a law
has the ability to engage in expenditure
to voice their opinion about either an
issue or a candidate in an electoral
process
it's called independent expenditures
versus what contributions and there are
many in this debate that blur those
lines to try to say that a candidate is
receiving the unlimited resources of a
corporation to get elected to a
particular office and that's just simply
not the case States and the federal
government have the authority to cap or
limit the amount of contributions but
what the Supreme Court has said is that
there's no authority that the government
possesses to cap free speech and that's
what Citizens United
equals and that that is a that is a case
that is going to be front and center
into the future as it relates to
decisions we already have four members
of the court that are willing overturn
citizens united clearly we have four
members of the court that are our I
think posture did it to overturn Heller
so we know in the religious liberty
context whether his little sisters the
poor Hobby Lobby or the denial cert in
this last case that there are four to
limit attract privatize the view the
first amendment is relates to free
exercise so these are very important
cases we go forward the other case that
I've mentioned in the free speech
context is the Friedreich's case that
was was also impacted this particular
session in this term a case out of
California a non right-to-work state
teachers there in California they wanted
to make sure that as they gave there was
compulsory dues that were that were
being paid to the Union the teachers
union in California and those dues were
being used to advance what issues that
were contrary to the beliefs of the
individual teachers and so there was a
suit that was pursued by those teachers
to say that's a denial of my First
Amendment rights
unfortunately that case was lost before
the Supreme Court this particular term
so I think as you look at the First
Amendment as you look at free exercise
and free speech prospectively the
importance of who replaces Justice
Scalia and the principles that they
embody will make a huge difference in
the liberties and freedoms that we have
in the future now I do want to say that
this issue again is not just about a
vote things in Washington sometimes
there's simplified to a point of saying
this is just about a fifth vote on the
US Supreme Court literally a fifth vote
matters in these cases but again I think
as important is attitude and belief and
what the judicial branch's role is in
our constitutional framework that
Justice Scalia represented I think that
there was a persuasion that Justice
Scalia offered to other colleagues in
the court that we never knew about that
we never saw I believe that he had many
discussions with Justice Kennedy about
certain cases that that perhaps
influenced his opinion or his ultimate
decision with respect to some key cases
Justice Scalia's passing is not just a
vote I think his his true impact on the
court is going to be felt for
generations ahead and I'm hopeful that
we can put somebody on the bench that
represents those principles otherwise we
will see an imbalance a court a judicial
system that has become our ruler which
is inconsistent with what the founders
intended that branch of government to be
to be engaged so it has been a joy to be
with you here and I know that we're
going to have a time of question if I'm
not mistaken and answer how much time
have I have I've taken too much or too
little or about right okay yeah so about
15 minutes or so queuing so I think I
get a chance to play TV host here and
just take questions and
and in and hopefully answer them well
hey Chuck how's it going do you mind if
I get this feeling right here first
because yet yeah hello Matt how are you
hi I'm just a quick question for you
thank you again for your comments this
is very interesting what are your
thoughts about the 17th amendment the
repeal of the 17th amendment and
Scalia's thoughts I'm regarding that
well I mean there are a lot of things
that are being discussed right now I
think that are all the way including an
article v convention that that are I
think are important to the debate that
we see I'm actually supportive of a
repeal of that I think it's important I
think as close as we get to what the
founders vision equalled is is essential
to the future of Washington working the
way that it should I mean from it from
an attorney general perspective many
folks think that our cases that we've
brought against the federal government
emanate from the 9th or 10th amendment
and they don't most of them most of them
are simply cases that are about
statutory construction they truly are
examples of an executive branch doing
one of two things either either
pinch-hitting for Congress which is the
immigration case you've heard the
president say I've got a pen and a phone
many times and the president immigration
context said Congress has not acted
Congress has not acted the way I want
them to act someone acting into place 27
states joined together we get to respond
to the executive in Miranda and get to
stay that I referenced and then we have
other instances that I've talked about
today which is statutory language that
Congress has passed that the executive
branch is trying to reimagine
reinterpret to its own end so there is a
there truly is an attitude in Washington
that the states are mere vessels a
federal will and and so long as they act
in accordance with the federal
government's view under each of these
piece of legislation or constitutionally
things are fine
but but when States actually engage and
exercise the authority that they possess
that's where the conflict of the tension
rises and I think that particularly
is one is it goes to the heart of what
those individuals in the US Senate are
there to do and they're there to do what
primarily give voice to the state's
interest in this this debate this
discussion about federalism and the role
of Washington DC and the promise of the
states and so do I have much hope that
that will occur I don't I don't know if
you've got it you know any kind of you
know Yogi Berra I've mentioned that the
baseball-reference Yogi Berra one time
said predictions are pretty tough
particularly about the future and so you
know as we look at those kinds of issues
and try to predict whether that's
possible or not you know we shouldn't
engage in that probably but but I'll do
it anyway I you know I don't I don't see
much I don't have much optimism that
that's going to occur but it's a it's a
good question and one that that I would
answer the way that I did
Chuck yes sir thank you for being here I
agree with you I feel good in here by
the way I mean it's just glorious in
here right I mean it's just it's cool
and it's warm outside US feel it's
refreshing thank you for having the air
conditioning on about 65 it feels good I
mean this this this is like home to me
I mean I walk in at home and I like to
have it on about 68 despite what
President Obama thinks I should be doing
on cost that's the reason I want coal to
keep being burned across this country so
I can have low at electricity rates and
I keep it at 68 I'm sorry truck i
diverted i digress a little bit so no
this doesn't address justice scalia but
more the bigger picture which is what
you talked about as far as the rule of
law and I think that's what separates
the United States from many third world
countries and we have a justice or
injustice Department at the federal
level that as you mentioned in the
previous question likes to impose its
will on the states they want to enforce
certain laws and they don't want to
enforce other laws whether it's about
traditional marriage or about drug laws
you know they sort of pick and choose
what they want to enforce and it's I
guess my question is at what point given
the example of our federal
Justice Department do citizens actually
start picking and choosing what laws
they want to obey if law enforcement is
picking and choosing what laws they want
to enforce well I don't agree with you
and I are on the same page here that the
the attitude of the Justice Department
and we've seen this with state attorneys
general as well very close to here the
Virginia Attorney General and and also
the California Attorney General so this
is something that state attorneys
general engaged in to but I'm not one of
those that believe that I have some sort
of preference or prerogative to pick and
choose which laws I defend I give you a
great example when I came into office in
2010 I was elected in November of 2010
sworn in in January of 11 I inherited a
constitutional amendment to our
Constitution Oklahoma State Constitution
dealing with Sharia law and and the
language was clearly not going to pass
constitutional review we knew that I
mean I looked at it and I told the
legislators who passed it privately this
is something that's not going to survive
and I don't I don't really think the way
that you did it was the right way to do
it but guess what Chuck we went to the
courthouse and we put on the best case
we could we we advocated as best we
could and we got b-but-but
but that is not even what you're talking
about you're talking about a situation
where those in the executive branch
Attorneys General at the state level or
our Justice Department from a policy
perspective are saying I don't agree
with a policy of what that law says and
so therefore I'm just simply not going
to do what defend it and that is
absolutely 100% wrong and it's it's it's
a bad example and it causes confusion
amongst the electorate I think about how
those things should be done I'll mention
the case that's not terribly popular
particularly I mean I'm good for
instance with the folks Cato we hang out
together on some issues but they're not
sir they've not been terribly happy with
me about my lawsuit against Colorado
with respect to marijuana and and
going to take this opportunity to share
something with you about that case
because it is relevant to Chuck's
question we have a law at the federal
level called the Controlled Substances
Act right and and that law designates
marijuana as a controlled and dangerous
substance right now we have a also have
a Supreme Court case that says that the
Controlled Substances Act is
constitutional under the Commerce Clause
now what do you agree with that or not
we have a Supreme Court decision and we
have a federal law that says what
Colorado was doing the trafficking of
marijuana across state line and use of
possession internal to the state is what
unlawful there are federal felonies
being committed every single day in the
state of Colorado now as a good
constitutionalism I did not challenge
that portion of their law with respect
to use in possession the
decriminalization of possession within
the state of Colorado we challenged as a
state only that portion of amendment 64
that dealt with the commercialization of
marijuana across state line they're
exporting marijuana to 36 states across
the country over two tons of marijuana
has been exported from Colorado since
that since they passed it we seized 85
pounds of high grade marijuana in Custer
County two days after my lawsuit the
point I'm trying to make is I have said
to those at the federal level repeal the
law if you know if you want to to
effectively address if you want to
legalize if you don't want to prosecute
in this area because the Justice
Department has chosen not there's been
instruction to US Attorney's across the
country don't prosecute that crime so
for a state like Oklahoma who is not
legalized use possession in trafficking
and you see this the flood of marijuana
coming to your state what do you do is
the chief legal officer just turn the
head and say we're not going anything
about it or do you give meaning to the
statute and what the Supreme Court
decision is now again that's my job it's
not a policy decision that I'm making
and some sometimes people interpret
those kinds of actions those kinds of
lawsuits as being an opinion about
whether you know the efficacy of
legalization or decriminalization with
respect to marijuana and that's not what
I'm doing I'm simply trying to protect
our state's decision and give meaning to
the laws as passed by Congress and the
state of Oklahoma and Colorado but
despite all that it's a very very
controversial thing but but that's why
you know this issue chuck is an
important one because you have the
federal Justice Department in the
immigration context what do they say
categorical exemption not prosecute or
discretion I use that every day in the
office discretion of a prosecutor is to
look at the facts of law make a decision
about whether I prosecute case-by-case
right it's not to look at a statute and
say we're just gonna lop that part off
and 5 million people you're good that's
not discretion that's rewriting the law
and that's what the court said by the
way so this is a very important thing
that you've brought up Chuck and I hope
that we have a Attorney General in
January of 2017 that has the right view
of their job and and not this policy
driven view of their job that I think is
starting to dominate the discussion and
blood over into States Attorneys General
I got off a little bit there I'm sorry I
got the preaching a little bit got into
marijuana didn't you know I didn't you
know at those things I didn't mean to do
that forgive me yes sir I want that you
had a question my name is Howard Seger
mark I'm sorry my name is Howard
sohow mark would you discuss a little
bit about the attack on property rights
and the effect of that attack on the
other rights of American citizens you
have any specific areas that water ask
the forfeiture what areas well EPA comes
to mind okay okay well the one that's
most salient I think example of in
response to your question is the waters
the United States rule that was passed
by the EPA proposed and finalized that
was a direct attack on private property
owners across this country and you if
you're not familiar that case and you
have to remember that rule historically
and legally the EPA has authority over
waters that are what navigable that's
what the statute says the courts of se
and the EPA didn't like that constraint
they don't like to be controlled by
Congress they like to pontificate and
reimagine things as I've already
indicated so they issued a rule it
changed the definition of what
constitutes of water the United States
by saying that so long as there was a
nexus to navigability then they had
jurisdiction so what did that mean and
also in Oklahoma
well announces Oklahoma southwest
Oklahoma we have a lot of dry creek beds
we've had drought conditions there for
last seven to eight years that's where
the Air Force Base is located by the way
and so so 90% of the year we may have a
dry creek bed heavy rain standing water
10% of the year we have water in that
dry creek bed the EPA was a starting
jurisdiction over that drug treatment so
that so that if there were any land use
decisions being made farming or ranching
oil and gas building a subdivision any
of those actions that you've taken
historically in fact we had examples of
individuals who had thousands of acres
who simply wanted to build a pond on
their own land and it perhaps impacted
one of these dry creek beds before they
could build a pond on their own land not
for commercial purpose for anything like
that they had to go to what the EPA to
get permission to use their own land in
that way that's the that's how impactful
this rule was we challenged that 31
states we led the effort there 31 states
challenged that we won that case and got
a stay of enforcement against the EPA
they were reimagining what constitutes
of water of the United States under the
law so that's an example of the attack
it looked that was about one thing in my
my opinions about power it was about
jurisdiction and the authority of
Washington DC to determine how we're
going to use our land in Oklahoma or
every state across the country and that
just so incongruent inconsistent with
the framework that we've described and
we know that the founders created so
it's been great to be with you any more
questions can I take one more question
cuz this is late
two more oh you got a question or you
are you give me a signal okay I thought
you were give me a signal you're like my
third-base coach when I was playing
baseball I never could figure out what
the guy was saying you know he'd do this
and do this you know I don't know if I
was both to bunt
you know steal what hid away so one
thing Scalia was noted for was the
chevron doctrine
yeah actually creating a lot e right
yeah creating a lot of deference to
agencies and that seems to be one of the
really big questions I was curious if
your thoughts and what people should
think about regard to administrative law
off the next yeah we all make mistakes
right so so I think that Justice Scalia
was darling back his he wrote an article
Law Review article I think in 1989 two
years after he had been on the court
speaking very favorably about the
survivability
the longevity of the Chevron he didn't
he was actually not on court with
Chevron was decided as you know but he
spoke very favorably about Chevron and
then reinforced it in some decisions
afterwards I think it is it is a one of
the singular most important issues that
we face from a regulatory in the history
of law perspective this idea that that
agencies just because of who they are
receives some sort of tipping the scales
in their favor in and carrying out the
responsibilities that's given to them by
Congress Chevron deference in my view
should be overturned Congress should
speak to it I know there's something
called the reins act that's being
proposed and discussed in Congress that
doesn't go necessarily directly to the
to Chevron deference but look when you
combine delegation and deference in the
regulatory state we have in this country
today we don't govern ourselves anymore
as we should in my view there are two
things that need to happen Congress
needs to do its job actually send people
to Washington DC that understand the
role is to legislate legislate
legislation is hard work but legislation
should not be we like clean air so go
make clean air you what do you all think
I mean that's something that that that
bothers me is that Congress then gives
to the EPA this general grant of
authority and then what happens EPA
issues rules that we find oppressive we
find intrusive we find we don't like
them and what are the congressmen do
they go back to Oklahoma we've got good
possession
say that they go back to other parts the
country and they say we didn't do that
the EPA did that and so it gives them
clean hands quote-unquote to basically
delegate their authority in the way that
the founders never intended so the
courts need to get serious about
enforcing the non delegation doctrine
which emanates out of separation of
powers number one and number two the
court needs to overturn Chevron to say
that as those agencies engage in
regulatory action they don't get this
get-out-of-jail-free card deference you
guys are great so you know the scales
tip in your favor no they don't get a
chance to use Chevron deference to do
what change the statute change the
language it's it's frustrating to me
because we deal with this firsthand I
mean we sit in my office and we look at
cases and we say can we overcome Chevron
and they've clearly acted in ways that
are inconsistent with the language of
the statute but you know the courts are
going to begin with this attitude of
saying well they win if there's a tie in
fact I would say you this it's even more
than that right you guys have to do more
they you know they they are so trusted
they're so believable they're so
credible we love them so much that
they're going to get the benefit in this
proceeding so look I if I had an opinion
that's what I would say Chevron
deference ago should go away what do you
think thumbs up alright thumbs up and we
have one other question this young lady
here I'm
the Nationals game last night you know
every time I've come into town I've
looked at the schedule and I've wanted
to go watch the Nationals game I've
never been to Nationals Park you know
I've gone to all these parks across the
country and I hear great things about
your Park here and and and so my lovely
daughter takes me to dinner last night
because it's Father's Day and she treats
me to a wonderful wonderful meal and
then I get back in my staffers say I
went to the baseball game and so I had
this just conflict that maybe we should
have done the baseball game okay now I'm
not sure but I want to go check out your
all stadium because I hear it's
wonderful is it good have you all been
you haven't been maybe we should go yeah
yes in your talk you mentioned that
Oklahoma because of the number of people
has only five representatives in the
representatives my question to you would
be what do you think about statehood for
the District of Columbia where the
citizens have absolutely no rights they
can't vote in national elections they
can't even have any control over their
own budget including from money that
they received from DC income not from
the federal government you know I I
would say to you a couple things I
haven't I haven't really given a
tremendous amount of thought to that as
you might imagine but but you would
there have to be a great deal of
persuasion deployed to convince me that
DC needs to be a state uh and maybe that
could occur but I'm not for at any more
states at this juncture for several
different reasons but that's just where
I start you know and maybe I could be
persuaded otherwise but it's just not
something that I've thought a lot about
I hear what you're saying as far as the
the representation in Congress but it's
something that I would start from the
premise of saying no more states and
until we learn more about it well I
wouldn't like it but but but but that
but but you know we became a state in
1907 and I'm I'm really focused upon
making sure that that original charter
you know our equal footing
to the to the to the union is respected
by the courts in Washington DC it's just
I mean honestly it's not something I've
spent a lot of time thinking about but
I'm just being very honest with you it
would take you know some persuasion to
to convince me that we need to add
another state DC or otherwise so perhaps
you can do that go for a baseball game
and and and can get into that yes sir
Walter Weber American Center for Law and
Justice one of the problems as I see it
with the federal overreach is that
they've got the states on the dole
states what I'm sorry on the dole the
the the executive branch can say do it
our way
or we're gonna yank your money and I
think there's a frayed that as long as
that steady flow of money from States to
DC and then back after the States
continues the states will always be in a
position where they could be intimidated
is there any way of undoing that well
look I mean the court the court address
that to a certain degree in the NFIB
versus civilities in fact it did address
it with the Medicaid aspect and that the
governors across the country that are
making decisions about Medicaid
expansion didn't even have that right
until we brought the lawsuit our our
claim there was that the decision about
Medicaid mandatory expansion violated
spending power it was a gun to the head
it was coercion it was intimidation
he was an entire change of the the
program that Medicaid historically you
know the people that had served and we
won that portion of the case but it did
highlight to your to your question the
importance of the decision that states
from making whether it's in the
transportation context but particularly
education context there's only one state
in the country I think it may be
Nebraska could be the state of DC in the
future I'm not sure that the the rejects
federal monies for education and they
have obviously none of the requirements
and mandates at Oklahoma faces as a
result so I think states do need to take
a serious look at whether the bargain
that's being struck between the federal
government and and and the respective
states to take money it comes with a
price and I would say to you it comes
with a substantial price and it comes
with a price that then honestly if you
look at the bargain and actually put
numbers on the paper I know in the
education context that loser
Oklahoma you know the mandates that were
forced upon the state of Oklahoma we get
funded about 20 to 30 percent and so
we're picking up about 70% of those
mandates so it's a fair question to say
then why are we doing that I think it's
more of a choice though unless a legal
issue we really don't know at this
juncture what the court how the courts
going to apply NFIB versus a bilious you
know how are they going to look at this
gun to the head coercion type of we
don't know if it's you know focused upon
the definition of the program like it
was and if I be as far as Medicaid and
His purposes originally and it's a it
was a nun Maureen the that that occurred
through the mandate is it monetarily
driven you know if it's if there's so
much money in play that and in the end
the feds say you must do this is does
that qualify as violating spending power
so I think I think the development of
NFIB versus a bilious and the spending
power context is yet to be it's still
it's it's going to occur over time but I
think in the first instance states
really need to look at whether this
bargain that they're engaging in with
the federal government is a valuable one
and it's a good question we see it in
the transgender a case that the distance
on May 13th when the when the President
issued or the do II issued the
significant guidance respect to
transgender students and just this aside
comment that's another area that we see
great problems in the regulatory
framework is guidance versus rulemaking
we've seen it I've seen it firsthand we
had we had banks in Oklahoma when I
first came not within three months of
being in office I had a community bank
and I can't recall the community maybe
ADA or arm or I can't recall where it
was in the state that the FDIC came in
and said they had issued a guidance
document on overdraft protection and as
they were going through an examination
with this Bank they find the bank for
non-compliance with that guidance
document I found out about it and I sent
a letter to sheila bair chairman and the
FDIC at the time and and just simply
said last time I checked there's
something called Administrative
Procedures Act
it says that guidance does not rule and
went through the entire explanation they
quit doing it but that's what happened
to transgender situation significant
guidance by the Justice Department and
the department education reimagining
what constitutes gender under title 9
and 1972 amendments of the Civil Rights
Act and guess what's at issue about
twelve percent of the money in Oklahoma
is are those dollars about half a
billion dollars so the federal
government is saying to K through 12 and
higher you higher IDI in the state of
Oklahoma with respect to dormitories
with respect to locker rooms with
respect to athletics with respect to
bathrooms which is what gets the most
attention you do these things or else I
think there's spending power issue there
and in a potential violation that we're
going to prosecute in these cases so
your questions are very good one I think
in first instance at first instance the
case the states need to evaluate the
merits the bargain the policy decision
on whether to engage in that negotiation
with Washington DC for money the court
has talked about it the court has talked
about it many times and I've weighed in
and I think the court would say look
states y'all need to I mean I think
they'd say what I just said you need to
look at this this situation when whether
it's it you know good for you or not a
bit if you do the state the feds do have
an ability to leverage you to a certain
degree the question is that are they
leveraging it too much what are the
questions you have I think I'm getting
the third-base coach here saying that
it's time to take the stops